let's think about the infinite series so
we're going to go from n equals 1 to
infinity of 1
over
2 to the n plus n and what i want to do
is see if we can prove whether this
thing converges or diverges and as you
can imagine based on the context of
where this video shows up on khan
academy that maybe we will do it using
the comparison test at any point if you
feel like you can kind of take this to
the finish line feel free to pause the
video and do so
so
in order to kind of figure out or get a
sense for this series right over here it
never hurts to kind of expand it out a
little bit so let's do that so this
would be equal to when n equals 1 this
is going to be 1 over 2 to the 1
plus 1. so it's going to be 1 over 2
plus 1 is going to be 1 3
plus that's n equals 1 when n equals 2
it's going to be 1 over 2 squared which
is 4 plus 2 plus 1
over 6
plus
let's see when we go to
when we go to
3 that equals 1 n equals 2 n equals 3
it's going to be 1 over 2 to the third
which is 8 plus 3 is 11. so 1
over 11. maybe i'll do one more term 2
to the fourth power is going to be 16
plus 4 is 20 plus 1
plus 1 over 20 and obviously we just
keep going on and on and on
so in order to use so it looks it feels
like this thing
could converge all of our terms are
positive but they are going they're
getting smaller and smaller quite fast
and if we really look at the if we look
at the
the behavior of this this the terms as n
gets larger and larger we see that the 2
to the n in the denominator will grow
much much faster than the n will so this
will start to behave this kind of
behaves like 1 over 2 to the n
which is a clue of something that we
might be able to use for the comparison
test so let me just write that down so
we have 1 over so the infinite series
from n equals 1 to infinity of 1 over 2
to the n
and so when n equals 1
you're this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1
half when n is equal to 2 this is going
to be equal to 1 4 when n is equal to 3
this is equal to 1 8 when n is equal to
4 this is equal to 1 16 and go on and on
and on and on
and what's interesting about this is we
recognize that this is a geometric
series so let me be clear this thing
right over here
that is the same thing as the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity
of one-half
to the n power just writing it in a
different way and since the absolute
value of one-half which is just one-half
so because
because
the absolute value of one-half is less
than one we know that this geometric
series converges
we know that it converges and actually
we even have formulas for finding the
exact sum of or to find this exa
figure out what it converges to
and so we know this thing converges and
we see that actually these two series
combined meet all the constraints we
need for the comparison test so let's go
back to what we wrote about the
comparison test so the comparison test
we have two series all of their terms
are greater than or equal to zero all of
these terms are greater than or equal to
zero
and then in and for the corresponding
terms in one series all of them are
going to be less than or equal to the
corresponding terms in the next one and
so if we look over here we could
consider this one the magenta series
this is kind of our infinite series of
dealing with a sub n and that this right
over here is well i already did it in
blue this is kind of the blue series and
notice all their terms are non-negative
and the corresponding terms
one-half is greater than one-third
one-fourth is greater than one-sixth
one-eighth is greater than one-eleventh
one over two to the n is always going to
be greater than 1 over 2 to the n plus n
for the n's that we care about here and
since we know that this converges since
we know that the larger one converges
it's a geometric series where the common
ratio the absolute value of the common
ratio is less than one since we know
that the larger series converges
therefore the smaller series or the one
that's where every corresponding term is
less than the one in the in the blue one
that one must also converge so by the
comparison test
so by the comparison test the series in
question must also
must also
converge